[Música]
de médico e louco todo mundo tem um
pouco
é eu espero que tenha mais médicos do
que de boa-fé é e vamos começar a
palestra genética no dna de longe dos
sonhos de criança para começar essa
palestra é apesar de não estar aqui como
médico estou aqui como palestrante
mas pra não sair o script eu gostaria de
discutir o caso clínico com vocês
eu gostaria que vocês pensar se
viajassem comigo nessa criança voltou
com os dados dela durante nossa conversa
e aí é eu gostaria que vocês pensem
comigo onde está essa criança hoje que
se for o que faz essa criança é uma
criança que nasce uma cidade do interior
de minas ela nascer um bairro de
periferia
a sipat é é uma comunidade os seus pais
emocionou primeiro os seus pais sua mãe
têm ensino fundamental incompleto até a
4ª série e o seu pai na sua vida
profissional sendo faxineiro em uma
escola na região onde nasceu ele é
caçula de uma família de quatro filhos
estudou a vida inteira em escola pública
eu gostaria que vocês viajassem comum
onde está essa criança agora em que se
formou com que se faz neste momento nós
vamos deixar essa criança de lado e nós
vamos discutir alguns conceitos metros
vai ser bem fácil e no final a gente
volta com essa criança
a primeira coisa que gostaria de
discutir com vocês é sobre ter
desenvolvimento cerebral
algumas pessoas ou a grande maioria
acredita que quando uma criança nasce o
seu cérebro já está totalmente formado e
eu gostaria de discutir falando sobre o
tamanho do cérebro no dia 01 dia de
nascimento
ela criança o seu cérebro pesa 400
gramas
o seu cérebro pisou 400 gramas desse
tipo com um ano de vida um ano
o cérebro dessa criança já está pesando
aproximadamente 800 grandes com dois
anos de vida o cérebro dessa criança vai
pesar
mil e cem gramas mil e cem gramas e
pasmem o seu cérebro hoje ou cérebro de
uma pessoa quando chega na vida adulta
não ultrapassa mil 350 gramas
isso nos mostra a importância do
desenvolvimento cerebral
os primeiros anos de vida se o seu
cérebro continuasse a crescer
da forma como cresce nos primeiros dois
anos
ele chegaria por volta de 70 anos
pesando 50 quilos
imagina com você andar com a cabeça com
cérebro de 50 quilos
aliás você não me engana que porque com
a cabeça de 50 quilos ninguém anda e tem
muita coisa não é só o desenvolvimento
cerebral desses primeiros anos de vida
de uma outra coisa que chega a me
arrepiar falando com o neurologista e
arrepia é fantástico
o cérebro logo após o nascimento
ele começa a desenvolver novas conexões
chamadas sinapses
o nome é difícil mas eu gostaria que
vocês pensarem comigo como se fosse um
filho uma casa formando tomadas a cada
um
ele forma novas tomadas novas tomadas
novas tomadas ao ponto que por volta de
dois anos dois anos
essa criança vai formar sete certas
novas tomadas por mim imagina informando
700 novas tomadas comentou
sua casa e consensos anos
essa criança terá 4 trilhões de novas
tomadas 4 milhões de novas sinapses
isto é fantástico que servem essas
finanças em assinar serve para tudo
elas ajudam no movimento elas ajudam no
raciocínio controla as nossas funções
fisiológicas
ela é tudo então se você imaginar que
nós tivemos uma criança no dia 01 em uma
cabeça como se fosse um computador pc
500 o primeiro computador nasceu e que
ela vai fazer novas conexões de forma
progressiva até chegar por volta de seis
anos ela vai ter como se fosse o melhor
contador dono o melhor lutador da nasa
isso é fantástico eu posso colocar tudo
que eu quiser um computador todas as
informações está pronto para ser
colocado
isso não é a única coisa fantástica que
eu tenho pra falar pra vocês eu tenho
para falar sobre o terceiro concerto
desta noite o terceiro conceito que é
difícil nome mas que vocês também vão
entender que é uma coisa muito simples
ep genética é é acima
mais do que a genética até pouco tempo
atrás quando ainda não tínhamos
conhecimento do projeto genoma humano
nós achávamos que nosso dna era
responsável e nós não importava nos com
meios mas aí nós fizemos um projeto
genoma e descobrimos que se não é
totalmente verdade e descobriu se que o
dna
ele não é fixo ele pode ser remodelado
ele pode ser militar
cara esse médico tá bom tá falando que
meu dna que todo mundo falou que era
fixo vai mudar e é isso mesmo
seria como se nós tivéssemos o nosso dna
as grandes
das nossas cidades programadas para
chegar a determinados locais
mas à medida que o meio externo provocou
uma erosão provoca uma tempestade
esse dna como novo canal o problema é
que esse novo caminho
pode-se levar para um lugar com 1 mas
também pode levar para mudar a imagem
você é uma criança nos primeiros anos de
vida se eu resposta é um fator que
provoca câncer
eu tenho certeza que você concorda
comigo que essa criança terá mais chance
de ter câncer na vida adulta
imagine você é uma criança que é
submetido a um estresse tão grande na
infância que esse stress pode levar esse
dna a mudar se remodela e produzir
transtornos com doenças mentais
isso tudo já está aprovado o problema é
que nós médicos e os cientistas
falamos muito pouco sobre o que pode
acontecer de bom quando nós modelo anos
esse dna para as coisas boas
isso é pouco estudado mas nesse momento
você tem três conhecimentos mãos
desenvolvimento cerebral
neuroplasticidade aquela capacidade das
sinapses formar mudar isso explica
inclusive inclusive porque é que um
adulto tem uma vez e tem um derrame
ele fica com lado todo esquecido há
crianças nem mesmo descer o mesmo
derrame ela consegue andar por causa
dessas novas sinapses e a epigenética
capacidade de mudar o dna através do
meio externo
o meio manda o dna mudar muito bem
eu gostaria de discutir uma coisa com
vocês que não é um conceito mas é uma
informação as pessoas imaginam
ou vocês vocês se você imagina
o ponto tempo leva um sonho na vida de
um ser humano
os estudos mostram que um sonho da vida
de um ser humano leva para ir embora
para eu esquecer t
se eu realmente sonhar se eu realmente
desejar 35 anos 35 anos 35 anos é com
isso minha esposa que geralmente não
esqueço da cafeteria colomba você não me
deixou o primeiro pau mas eu vou voltar
lá é o sonho de comer qual eu tenho 12
anos um filho voltava completou
então os sonhos sonhos com 35 anos
agora preste atenção se juntarmos tudo
isso o desenvolvimento cerebral
fantástico novas sinapses capacidade de
mudar o dna da criança e os sons se eu
consigo implantar na cabeça dessa
criança sons
tenho certeza que vai acontecer
o sucesso financeiro sucesso como pessoa
aquela criança lá no começo vamos voltar
a falar aquela criança e seus pais são
muitos sonhos
apesar de ser zagueiro
era o sonho da vida seu pai e sua mãe em
apuros
queria que aquele menino se transformar
assim um grande grande pessoa que mudar
sua vida das pessoas que conseguisse
contagiar e aquela família começou nova
nos primeiros anos de cabeça ao ponto de
que os seus pais traziam informações
fotografias de outras cidades de outros
países pra ele
londres paris nova york
mesmo sem saber se teria dinheiro para
ir a belo horizonte
o rio de janeiro eles não tinham medo
dos sonhos
eles não tinham
eles vinham atrás
ao ponto de uma certa vez essa criança
falou assim
pai quero ser médico a partir daquele
momento a partir daquele momento o seu
pai começou a levá lo às consultas com
ele para ver como médico trabalhava
inter tentava que se entendeu e pela sua
monarquia 77 vezes colocava a garrafa ea
porta do hospital só para ver os
funcionários entrar e sair
estava bem no hospital a lifan taste
todo trabalho que a coloca na cabeça
daquela criança que ela podia trabalhar
para desenvolver um sonho da vida aquela
criança mas a vida a vida na caixinha de
surpresa e essa criança começou a
estudar logo no primeiro ano de vida no
primeiro ano da escola
ao começar a organização descobriu os
que ele tinha um problema se ele fosse
no meu consultório onde teve o
diagnóstico discalculia disortografia
ele não se previa direito mas graças a
deus ele foi reprovado e repetiu o
primeiro ano e nesse primeiro ano
repetindo ele encontrou uma professora
que decorre que levava ele para casa
dela que trazia pé da gente na grafia
para escrever que estava na hora em que
entrei e colocava na cabecinha dele
você pode escrever melhor você pode
fazer melhor
você pode ser melhor isso se for
reprovado você é mais inteligente de
salvador
mas a vida a vida é uma caixinha de
surpresa logo no ano seguinte
essa criança é essa mesma professora fez
uma bagunça santo não é pra mim
teve um outro diagnóstico tv água ia
fazendo essa bagunça na sala a
professora pegou e colocou o último
lugar
você vai ficar lá tanto no último lugar
ea professora deu sua aula encheu 4
enche e ao final da aula ele chegou
perto dessa professora chegou perto dele
falou
mas apesar de fazer o anúncio da minha
sala e ainda não escreve o que eu fiz 14
você está demais ele disse não o fez
a senhora não inscrevê lo para longe
naquele momento naquele momento ela
entendeu que podia ser um problema
visual e foram à praça diagnóstico essa
criança havia perdido aproximadamente
70% da sua qualidade visual do lado
esquerdo
ela tinha 8 graus de visão no olho
direito e mais uma vez aquela professora
ajudou a construir sonho daquela criança
ea vida tá parecendo josé filho né
a vida é uma caixinha de surpresa
o álbum terceiro ano aquela criança
estava em casa na hora da disputa se
chamava morre vai com toda criança
curiosa ver o que está acontecendo e ao
chegar na porta da casa se depara com o
assassinato
um tio tá na fácil de uma amiga
transfixou a cabeça um corpo no chão eo
menino ao lado
para muitos é demais mas não é é a
realidade de muitos brasileiros
como se não bastasse aquele bate um
órgão nos meses seguintes longos meses
seguintes
uma nova tragédia uma nova tragédia
ele estava jogando bola no campo de
futebol com seu irmão primo irmão e os
pais que estavam
de repente saí pó e o irmão atrás eo
apostava corrida e ele caiu
o em locais sobre o joelho do irmão bate
no chão uma ferida uma ferida que em
três dias ia se transformar para
infeccioso uma sepse e a morte do irmão
mais uma vez naquele momento a família
ea escola se o professor entender que
ele podia mais e começou a trabalhar com
ele mesmo não sendo mais professora ele
tanto esforço
chamava os pais não resultava
provavelmente um processo depressivo ele
vai conseguir
ele não conseguiu mais ir à aula nem
voltar da aula voltará ao entardecer
isso prejudicar mas qualquer ajuda da
família aquela ajuda da professora os
sonhos longo dos meses seguintes
essa criança entendeu que realmente ela
podia mais que ela podia ir com seus
sonhos e funk e foi o iphan
se você ainda não entendeu ou não sabe
do que estou falando
talvez você conheça essa pessoa que fala
é essa
eu gostaria de deixar nesta tarde uma
mensagem para vocês que não corro dos
sonhos dos seus filhos não corra do
sonho dos seus amigos dos seus sobrinhos
assim vamos construir uma nova escola e
eu convivo nesse momento para subir ao
palco
a minha professora dos meus pais
[Aplausos]
[Música]
abraão
a 0
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]